thanks everyone for coming to this talk
my name is Gabby shklovsky I work for
revenue analytics based in Atlanta
Georgia and there's a little bit about
us we're a check enable consulting firm
that helps some of the world's biggest
companies make their biggest revenue
decisions such as what to charge what to
put what to stock and what to promote
when so obviously in helping companies
make those decisions
machine learning perceive analytics are
a big part of that and that was what
kind of brings our interests to rain and
forests and kind of from my motivation
for this talk was I've seen random
forests become a lot more popular over
the past several years and there are
tools great tools like scikit-learn
which makes it really easy to get
started with kind of just dumping your
data in and seeing what happens but I've
also seen a lot of kind of colleagues
and friends that try this and it just
don't get great results when you just
kind of do that let's hey and let me
dump my data into this model and see
what happens so just wanted to kind of
share some best practices that I've
learned over the years that can
hopefully be be helpful to others as
well so our agenda here I'll just start
with a brief overview of what random
forests are then get into some best
practices for training them where the
ideas how do we get the best predictions
possible from the data available and
then spend a lot of time getting into
best practices for interpreting random
forests so aside from our typical kind
of accuracy metrics and whatnot in
machine learning how do we interpret the
results coming out of random forests so
things like soundchecking model outputs
and kind of breaking inside that black
box to write insights to skeptical
business leaders so let's get started
with that random forest overview so at a
high level
run forest center type of machine
learning algorithm snows ensemble
methods so it's all methods just use
multiple machine learning models which
together give Begg approach of
performance than any one component would
on its own and rain forests are just in
samples of decision trees so the idea is
you would train multiple tree models and
you blend the predictions of each to
determine the combined prediction so
kind of a parallel set of trees that you
kind of combine to get a single
prediction and we run far
considered to be black box model so it
just means that they have a complex
structure not necessarily easily
interpreter printable to humans but as
I'll get into a little later the fact
that they do have this underlying tree
based structure does allow for at least
a little bit more human interpret will
incite that may be your typical black
box algorithm and of course was one of
the kind of big questions you guys well
what's a random about them what why is
this randomness important to a random
forest and if you think about a kind as
I mentioned it's a collection of
decision trees but decision tree
algorithms are deterministic which means
that if you have a single input data set
and you feed it into a decision tree
algorithm you're always going to get the
same tree back so if we just took that
same data plugged in three times we're
gonna get thirty identical trees that's
not really helpful we're not not getting
any value out of that so we need
randomization to produce in samba 'ls of
trees that are each somewhat different
and so random forests typically use ran
us on two dimensions the first is random
sampling of data so it's probably the
more obvious one this is typically done
using bootstrapping which is sampling
with replacement so the idea is now
instead of having 30 trees trained on
the exact same data set there now each
trained on slightly different data sets
and that allows each tree to fit to
slightly different patterns in the data
that seeing so you would get kind of
slightly different results in each and
the second way randomness is
incorporated is in the random sampling
of possible split variables so it's a
slightly more nuanced so if you think
about having a tree work so you can look
kind of at this tree model on the left
is at each node at each level in the
tree it is choosing among all of your
predictors to say which predicted which
variable will give me the best split and
where should I split it so in a typical
decision tree like the one on the Left
let's say we had four predictors in the
model customer type number of employees
Selma Austria region the decision tree
algorithm decide hey I get the best
split if I split on number of employees
at the value of a thousand and that will
basically do
every level in the tree and that's how I
built out the tree whereas what we do in
the random forest to kind of bring in
this randomness is you randomly restrict
this set of potential split variables so
we can see on the right we've eliminated
number of employees and sell them out
last year its candidates we restrict
ourselves to only two predictor
valuables variables as options and then
choose the best among them so what that
kind of does is it disrupts that
greediness of the split variable
selection so instead of just kind of
optimizing for each node each level of
the tree we're just an injecting a
little bit of randomness maybe by
smoking on customer type we get a little
bit worse fit at the next level but we
could actually get a better fit a few
levels down conversely we could just get
worse fits all the way down and that's
why we want to build multiples of these
trees and blend them all together to get
to get the best predictive result so
that kind of at a high level is random
farce and what does random about them
and now we can start getting into what
are our best practices for training
random farce and we're talking about
training a lot of it has to do with
structuring the model and kind of data
prep so best practice number one which
is common thing I see a lot is it's
really important you factor out linear
relationships between predictor and
response so a random farce is a
collection of trees trees having
nonlinear structure it's a tree
structure if we have linear
relationships within the model it just
it generally doesn't tend to perform
well a tree will try to approximate
something as linear and that's just not
a great thing to do it will overpower
subtler effects that we might be more
interested in learning about so we
wanted to stick with the idea of what
each model do it does best if you have
parts of your problem that are linear
and let's just go ahead and use a linear
model for those parts if you have parts
that are nonlinear well hey random fires
might be a really great option for
getting good predictive power for the
nonlinear components so can I highlight
this and
I'll use this example throughout the
talk is just pulled some data for a b2b
company that wants for dick customer
spend next year this is a company that's
selling a product to businesses and they
have some data on what the customers
have spent over the previous few years
and some customer attributes and I want
to kind of build some predictive models
of what do we expect a customer to spend
with us next year that could be an
important input for let's say their
their sales team of knowing who should
we target to make sure like they're
spending they're not going to drop us
next year or they're not gonna spend
less with us where we're gonna target
our discounts excited cetera so that's
kind of the problem we're looking at and
so just start if we kind of just easily
forget into a random forest model and
use last year spend as one of the
variables to predict next year spend
we'll see that the last year spend will
completely dominate our trees what's so
kind of have a single tree on the side
here what I did was fit a random forest
with scikit-learn I believe with with 30
trees and just randomly pulled one out
and I applauded the result and so
because what a customer spent last year
is highly linearly kind of related to
what they're gonna spend the following
year we see that the tree is basically
just approximating that one year
relationship so can you see the first
node split where someone last year
smoking on less they're equal to about
forty two thousand says hey if they
spent more than 42,000 last year they'll
probably spend we say they'll send
65,000 next year and if you go the far
left of the tree if they spent less than
8,000 last year you predict they'll
spend 5500 next year so this isn't
really adding a whole lot of new
information if you were to show this to
some your like sales executive they'd be
like well yeah I know that people that
spent roughly 50k last year probably
gonna spend roughly 50k next year the
ones that spent roughly 10k last year
will spend roughly 10k next year that's
that's not really helping me that's
that's not having a whole lot of value
what we really want to go after some of
those more second-order effect
more interesting so we can get a better
result by doing something as simple as
changing the target variable to be a
linear transformation so we're now
predicting cell amount difference which
is the difference between cell amount
which is the variable we were trying to
predict originally and what a customer
spent last year so we're kind of
internalizing that business intuition
that hey we know people spend roughly
the same amount your rear so the but I
really want to know is that person that
spent 50k last year are they gonna spend
51 K next year or 49 K next year because
that's really going to inform how I'm
gonna approach that that sales endeavour
how I'm gonna think about pricing how
I'm going to think about how many
resources to put into that relationship
so now with a new target variable we get
obviously a completely different model
I'm a very different looking tree so we
see other factors now come through as
predictive and so all of these factors
were included in the first mile we ran
they just didn't actually show up in the
tree
so you see customer type so this data
has customer types a B and C so we see
whether it's customer type a is
important we see number of employees
come through is important and
interesting enough we still see last
year span is predictive in a very
different way so if you look at kind of
that second level on the left with when
cell amount last year is higher the
difference tends to be larger that one
gets lower so maybe that's kind of a
little different insight than what we
learned in the original model so okay i
level having linear relationships kinda
thing you're in forest and within your
decision tree in general probably not
going to yield great results
so you really want to do this factor
that will you know relationship out in
this example it was as easy as kind of
just taking a difference so really
simple in your transformation in other
cases it might make sense to run a
simple linear regression as a first step
and train your your random forests on
the residuals that's kind of paradigm
that I've seen works really well so
that's kind of that's the high-level
idea with this best practice number one
but I just want to quickly call it one
more thing which is the R squared can be
really misleading especially
this case we were comparing a model with
a linear component versus one without so
we were one calling model a which is the
first one with a linear piece model B
was the second one where we use the
difference we see for model a the
r-squared was point eight six so if you
were naively just running this model and
all you were using was r-squared to
evaluate it you'd be like this is a
great model I'm done let's move on and
maybe if you saw that really lower
square 2.14 model B you'd be scared and
say hey I'm get me up on this let me try
something else but if we actually look
at other accuracy metrics like me for me
absolute percent error on our final
prediction we see that model bead is a
lot better than Model A once we kind of
apply that transformation to get the the
actual target value back so just kind of
a heads up be careful with R Squared's
it's I called out so I'm psychic learn
random forests regressor dot score uses
r-squared score so if that's kind of
your default scoring method maybe
consider other ones as well so just a
bit quick heads up there so knocking on
to best practice number two which is
that future engineering is key and think
this is kind of generally important for
many machine learning methods but I
wanted to get into a few few specific
ideas the first two oh I'll walk through
briefly and then the last one I'll
highlight with an example so number one
is just use domain expertise and
business knowledge as a guide I work in
consulting so we spend a lot of time
talking with our clients learning about
their business really understanding how
they think the world works kind of in
understanding their intuition for for
how their business works and so you
really want to take those ideas and kind
of think about how you can link them
back into features so if you are kind of
talking to the business and they say hey
I underst there's a strong relationship
between these two things well how do we
collect data on those things and either
confirm or deny that that exists or how
can that kind of inform our predictive
modeling the
one is to explicitly define interaction
effects as new predictors so this is
something that is always done in linear
regression models two people tend not to
do as much with tree based methods
because you kind of have the idea that
hey there's like this tree structure
maybe it'll split I'm variable a first
and then split on variable B next and
that will implicitly give me kind of an
interaction effect between a and B and
while that is true and that can work it
often doesn't work the way you expect
and that kind of comes back to the
greediness of how these algorithms work
that it's really when it's making those
split decisions it's treating each level
independently it's not thinking hey I
should split on a now because I'm gonna
get a better result if I spill on B next
it's gonna say no I'm just going to pull
out C now because that gives me the best
result one level down so if kind of from
your domain knowledge expertise from
your from your business knowledge you
strongly believe an interaction effect
exists hey look let's model that
directly as a predictor another thing to
note with with random forests kind of as
opposed to your linear regression model
is that it does feature selection for
you so if you kind of include additional
features that turn out to not be
predictive it doesn't really hurt your
model so kind of wandered out let's add
some extra predictors and that kind of
links into the third point which is
using multiple metrics that are proxies
for the same concept so this is one
we'll go into a little more detail with
on the next slide with an example but
the idea is hey maybe you learn from
from your your business knowledge that
there's some concept that we believe is
important in and predictive but we don't
have any data to measure it directly but
maybe we have two or three different
approaches that measure indirectly
instead of just picking one again like
you would probably do in in like a
linear regression sort of setting hey
let's let's just include all of them so
if we continue the example we were
looking at before but now I want to add
previously your spend difference as a
predictor so what we're predicting is
basically the difference in span between
what we can say is year one and year
zero but we all we know
you know what the difference in spend
was between your two men year one so if
a customer kind of spent more the
previous year do you think they're gonna
spend more again this year or maybe
they'll spend less this year so that
that can become another another
predictor we add to the model
whenever you're kind of think about
differences maybe you're thinking should
this be modeled as dollar or percent and
so here it's like why not both let's
just add both the dollar difference and
the percentage difference in the model
and the reason to do that so on it often
leads a better predicted performance
because maybe kind we can kind of think
about the tree structure that we have
maybe in some regions of your your
domain the percent is more predictive in
other regions
the dollar is more predictive so kind of
throwing them both in gives the model
the option to choose either what I've
also found is it can help you make your
model less vulnerable to outliers so
let's say you have some new observation
you're predicting and it has a really
large percent difference but a smaller
dollar difference because the
denominator is small then maybe if you
only trained using percent you would get
some kind of weird results in the output
because it would kind of over fit you
that hey it's a huge percent difference
that's weird I'm gonna give you a real
result out where as you're training on
both of them maybe some trees will kind
of train on the percent some trees will
train on the dollar and that leaves me
any impact you would get from having
kind of a weird percent value so this
kind of another because again we're
doing with like proxies for things for
like the true thing we're trying to
understand and if nope
some proxies may work better in some
situations than others so this kind of
helps us prevent our proxy from being
like an extreme outlier when in reality
the situation isn't really aware and so
the the day table I've shown here are
there are MAPE accuracy metrics for a
few different variations in the model so
if my model B was when we looked at
before and then I included different
variables in the model to see how the
accuracy would change so C and D each
included just one of those variables and
then we see the performance of
a little bit looking at accuracy and
maui ampere includes both and we got a
slight improvement in the MAPE from
sixteen point eight to sixteen point
seven so in this particular use case not
a huge game predict performance in other
cases maybe you get a little bit more
but kind of that's the idea with this
concept so just kind of a quick review
our best practices for training random
forests one let's factor out linear
relationships and to future engineering
is key this is a place to spend your
time really understand the problem
really understanding your data to get
the best results out of your model and
realizing that hey if you you started
using a linear type approach just taking
those same predictors and throwing them
into the random fires may not give you
the the best value you can because kind
of the types of predictors you might
want in those different situations might
be different okay
so that leads us into now best practices
for interpreting random forests there's
a note here like obviously a lot of what
you're thinking about when you're
evaluating models has to do with kind of
the accuracy of the model and and how
well it fits the data and there are tons
of ways to approach that and lots of
kind of literature out there and on how
to think about accuracy so it's not what
I'm going to focus on I'm more gonna
focus on how do you go about kind of
interpreting the results of random
forests especially in the business
context where as much as executives will
throw out all the big day of machine
learning buzzwords of I want this I want
that at the end of the day if you have a
model that no one understands what's
happening under the hood they're gonna
be really reluctant to let you actually
make decisions off of it which kind of
makes sense in a business context so
they also get at least some Interpol
output out is really important so our
best practice number three was
relatively simple just checking the
feature importances and that there's
aligned with our expectations intuition
so the future importance is going to
give you a measure of how important each
of the different metrics are in
agonistic power to your model so here
is a good what I find really useful with
this is checking hey are the things the
features that are listed as important
what you expect it to be important
enough not that's like a big red flag
that hey I probably screwed something up
along the way either my Dino is bad that
has missing values or I did some
transformation I didn't wrong or I did
screw something up with model fitting if
kind of something you expect to kind of
pop out doesn't pop that's just a really
quick hey let me dig into this deeper
and make sure I understand it kind of
regardless of what your accuracy metrics
are telling you looks great but if you
kind of see something new and different
you don't expect and you go through and
double-check your diene and double-check
your models and everything looks good
that can reveal some new business and
say of like hey our sales people don't
ever consider number of employees of the
company when they're thinking about who
they should target and how they should
price and all these different things but
this model is telling us like hey that's
pretty it seems to be free predictive so
because that give us a new insight that
can come in for our business strategy so
yeah kind of have this this chart but
continuing the same example with our
future importances for our model but the
thing that's really lacking from this is
it just telling you what is important so
I'm telling you kind of why or how the
number of employees variable is
affecting our predictions and so that
brings us to kind of our best practice
number four which is to check the
directional relationship between top
predictors in response I think this is
this is a really key thing again for
forgetting some some interpret e out of
the model and getting kind of your your
business folks your non-technical people
comfortable with what the model is doing
that not only do your accuracy metrics
and whatnot look great and not only are
you really smart and telling them that
like this is awesome
that when you put new data in it's
actually going to lead to good business
decisions and these directional
relationships have a lot to do with that
so if I'm have two approaches here which
will go into detail them both
the first is just to manually step
through a few levels of the trees to
detect pattern so just kind of really
simple what's eyeball it and see what's
going on
and then the second is to
stress test the model with some
synthetic data that varies the value of
one predictor while holding all is equal
so the first approach is just manually
stepping through trees it's just a
really great sanity check to again make
sure there are no bugs and your data or
your code or anything and that the model
just make sense so I took this model II
which I think had like 30 trees
I picked this is tree zero I'm just
picked one out and kind of clipped it to
the first five levels and we can kind of
just go and eyeball what the
relationships are based on the splits so
the first feature was our sell amount
last year difference percent and if you
kind of just look at that first split
one gets what's to the left which is a
lower value the value of the prediction
is higher than what's what's the right
and we see kind of that same pattern
again pre wherever every time it splits
that we get a higher value to the I
guess we get we got different patterns
at different levels but kind of the high
level pattern was the higher the SEL
amount last year difference percent the
lower the predicted sell amount so this
is kind of our regression to the mean
idea that hey if someone spent a little
bit more with you last year maybe
they'll spend a little bit less with you
this year maybe that's an interesting
insight we thought let's look at number
of employees we tend to see when number
employees is higher a lower predicted
SEL amount difference so that again can
be an interesting insight and of course
this is random forests its collection
multiple trees we want to make sure we
look at least kind of tuna three trees
because you're gonna see different
patterns and different trees so here I
pulled out tree six I'm just kind of
randomly selected one and we tend to see
the same general trends at a high level
but it may it may look slightly
different so you may just want to check
that you're not kind of overseeing a
relationship that isn't consistent
across the board so I'm I've only
manually subbing through those trees is
always a great place to start but it
would be nice if we could see a little
more systematically
the relationship is between the
predictors and the response so that's
where this idea of stress testing the
model can give you a more holistic view
of particular relationships so the idea
is to create some synthetic data that
changes a berries one feature while
holding all is equal but we have to
remember because it's a nonlinear model
it's kind of an ensemble method we need
to use multiple all else equal data sets
or else we could get misleading results
so you really want to think about this
in comparison to like a linear
regression model gives you write a
single coefficient that is basically
that directional that you've quantifies
that relationship between your predictor
and response any random first we're not
ever going to get that single number
it's gonna vary depending on kind of
where we are so I started to first
stress test cell amount last your
difference in dollars because that
didn't show up in the first few levels
of our tree and so the way I constructed
this table was basically each line i
selected ten random rows of data for my
holdout data set which is what each one
of those lines represents and then kind
of holding for each of those rows held
the value of everything else constant
well just changing the value along the x
axis of the one feature we're looking at
so you can see the depending on the
value of the other day of the other
features the level is certainly shifting
across those different rows but we do
see a pretty consistent pattern in how
it's varying along the x axis so we see
it's relatively flat through the middle
and we see this decreasing relationship
kind of above 4,000 or so so that's kind
of an interesting interesting insight
we've at least kind of better quantified
this relationship you can see the
regions in which it's flat versus where
it's negative and so I did this again
for the number of employees variable
because that one was kind of a little
more predictive a little more
interesting
and we see the chart looks pretty
different so again each row is each line
refers to kind of one row from the whole
dataset we're holding everything else
equal and
just varying the number of employees so
we see kind of some again we confirm
kind of that consistent negative
relationship we saw before but the size
of that relationship is definitely
varying depending on the value of the
other data that we're considering so
kind of those top few lines are pretty
flat so depending on kind of the value
of the other features for those number
employees isn't that predictive but kind
in the middle the chart it's very
predictive especially in this kind of
inflection point we're seeing between
1200 to 1400 employees so kind of itself
again can be an interesting business and
say of what is it when a company goes
from 12 on your employees to 1400
employees that leads to this huge
difference in behavior roughly all else
equal right so at least within each line
is kind of all else equal so that may be
something where now you can go back to
the to the business to the sales team
and say hey does this make any sense to
you and if not let's dig into it let's
talk to people let's let's understand
the data better and understand what's
going on so this is kind of I think a
really great approach for for again
pulling a little bit more systematically
that directional relationship out
knowing that you're never gonna boil it
down to like that single coefficient
like you get on your mall but you can
still kind of pull out some good
insights with an approach like this so
just kind of to summarize our two best
practices for interpreting random
forests first start with our feature
importances make sure they align with
expectations intuition it's a good way
to make sure we don't have any errors in
our code and then best practice before
let's take it a little bit further and
check those directional relationships I
think that's where you really get a lot
of bang for your buck in terms of
getting your business people your
non-technical people more comfortable
with what these models are doing and
kind of more willing to actually use
them to drive business decisions and so
with that I will open the floor
questions but my contact info up on the
page that I armed a chance to answer a
question today feel free to reach out
and I'd be happy to do so does anybody
have any does anybody have any questions
you raise your hand okay come on
Mike's coming you gotta be loud enough
for the recording yeah so the question
was um he loved the visuals and he
wanted to know what you were using for
the graphics on the trees and the
definition these guys yeah so I did it
it since I can't learn using the export
graph is function which yeah I think you
have to install like a third party like
GV editor yeah something like something
like that yeah tree object all right
cool yeah I was just checking to see it
was the same painful thing that I had to
do or if she found something better so
no it's the same painful thing excellent
talk thank you I was wondering if about
the idea of removing the linear
structure in the data you showed this
for a continuous outcome do you have any
intuitions for when we're doing a
classification task yeah that that's a
good thought I have not personally
worked with those problems as much so I
don't have kind of a personal experience
to draw on but I imagine you could get
similar a similar effect but yet it's
especially in a case where it's like as
simple as taking two different those
which I guess you're not really going to
get in classification it's kind of
really easy stuff there it just might be
a little bit more of a transformation to
do to factor that out
so when you say holding all else equal
in the context of your random forest
example like in linear regression you
could supplant
in the multivariate case you put the
means in and then you
perturb the variable of interest like in
this particular case are you basically
say you're trying to predict a
particular thing
you just keep its other variables what
they are and then perturb that
particular variable a lot yeah that's
the practice okay yeah so that and this
is kind of just to understand how the
model is working and understand yeah
trying to just isolate that relationship
between just that one predictor and and
response and there probably other ways
you can do this but yeah I just kind of
randomly sampled the data just to get
those kind of all else equal sets okay
yeah so the other variable is that
you're not interested in you keep those
as is mm-hm and then you flip it okay
[Music]
this is more of a high level question
around dealing with other businesses
because it sounds like in consulting you
would know a lot more about this and I
when you're talking about interpret E
and just using the models and having
them deployed or the businesses using
them do they ever ask about what happens
when they start using the model and then
their business changes and then what
happens to the model should they keep
using the model should they call you
back yeah yeah definitely so we run into
when you're obviously trying to build
models that are impacting business
decisions and how we deal a lot with
pricing inventory so these are things
that are kind of definitely changing
over time
yeah the if you're doing your job right
you're gonna kind of eliminate most of
the predictive power of your models over
time because you're gonna if your hand
up in like the self-fulfilling loop and
so kinda I think the best way you have
of doing that is well I think we try to
call like continuous learning where you
basically retain some sort of holdout
set over the long term so maybe 10% of
the time you don't use the model and you
just use whatever your old business
practice was and that way you can kind
of keep retraining the model on that
that sliver of the date of the business
because if yeah if not you could you can
run into problems with the entire nature
your business has changed now that
you've changed your business decision so
there's not a good solution to that
problem but that's probably if you even
if you've a high enough transaction of
volumes basically keeping kind of a
holdout set where you're not applying
the best strategy and then use that for
retraining the model yeah it's just
curious about how what's the best way to
create a synthetic data is for example
if you want to do some simulation study
using linear model you can generating
rendon C and it and it's very obvious
you can create a true model of that so
if you want to say test some methodology
then you want to create some simulated
data for random forest how you do how
would you do that yeah so I'm not sure
how you you would create like the best
synthetic data
my goal was more like let's let's just
do something simple and easy that's
gonna get us close to what we want
that's generally the approach I'll take
so yeah I'm not exactly sure they're
probably better ways you can kind of
explore this but my focus was yeah let's
just see something simple and hopefully
learn something from it my question
actually is like how do you make sure
your some set of data is realistic of
the real data yep
so I I think and I'll just come from
from just what kind of business
knowledge and understanding the data so
kind of and how I chose like the range
of the X values I looked at what have we
seen historically and then widened it a
little bit so that was was kind of how I
did that and then as far as the rows of
data I just randomly sampled ten rows
you could theoretically sample a bunch
more you can probably bootstrap and
create more if you want to be really
more precise and it's just gonna kind of
depend on your underlying data how much
variation you would see in a chart like
this if you were to kind of have more
robust synthetic data versus doing
something easy kind of if because in
this case the random fires I trained
were
that deep so there probably wasn't a
whole lot more you're gonna learn but if
you were training some more complex
models that were really deep and had a
lot of features thinking I having more
robust synthetic data would would be a
good call so my question is kind of on
since you probably use multiple
variations of different variables and
random forests say it uses like the
square root of the number of predictors
you're obviously going to set some
maximum depth as well maybe that's ends
up being say the number of predictors
square root of so that's something like
that so do you find it best in order to
like fine-tune all those hyper
parameters to kind of go ahead and run
through the data find that feature
impact and then cut out all of those
variables and retrain on that main top
subset or what are some of your
practices on depth and also like the
number of variables you used at each
split yeah I think so yeah it's good
playing around kind of at what station
and process you train your hyper
grammars and so I think I tend to kind
of take the first approach you described
of I'm going to pick some reasonable
parameters and do a lot of this sort of
feature engineering kind of
experimentation trying to get to a
pretty good model that I'm confident and
then kind of at the end then kind of go
back and do some more primer tuning once
I've kind of narrowed down the scope of
okay I know for sure what my target
variable is going to be because that
obviously can can definitely change what
the hyper primers look like I know more
so yeah which features are actually
predictive and time narrow down that
scope and in which all those different
components so yes I in terms of kind of
that area of cycle of experimentation I
find it easier to pick reasonable hyper
primers do a lot of the experimentation
and then go back and optimize them later
you